n'allons plus loin c'est notre grand
entretien nous recevons ce soir aya
cissoko championne de boxe écrivaine
comédienne metteuse en scène et femmes
engagés
son parcours est riche passionnant et il
s'est construit en grande partie sur le
sport c'est ce qui l'a sauvé dit elle et
c'est particulièrement important
d'entendre cela aujourd'hui parce que le
sport en ce moment en tant qu vide et
bien il y a un peu mis de côté les clubs
ont baissé le rideau est probablement
laissé pas mal de jeunes sur le carreau
elle nous dira si ça l'inquiète
illustration d'abord avec le bilan d'une
année sans sport sujet signé marie
brémaud en attendant la réouverture des
salles de sport certains français ayant
encore la motivation s'entraîne comme
ils peuvent pour des fois je vais aussi
avec une barre et j'utilise les pois
avec ma barque
donc voilà c'est vraiment on essaye de
s'adapter on essaye de faire comme on
peut mais après vivement que les salles
ou du sport à domicile en plein air
c'est un peu la débrouille et si les
professionnels du sport ont pu
poursuivre leur entraînement malgré les
confinements et les restrictions
ce n'est pas le cas pour beaucoup
d'amateurs adulte ou enfant privé pour
certains de pratiques sportives en club
depuis des semaines voire des mois
comme ici au club de boxe de garges les
gonesse en banlieue parisienne
son président s'inquiète pour bon nombre
de jeunes qui ne peuvent plus se
retrouver sur le ring
la conséquence elle est dramatique c'est
que les jeunes d'habitude ils ont des
repères
les jeunes ont des repères ils viennent
s'entraîner au club le club est ouvert
du lundi au samedi
donc c'est une deuxième famille est là
bas les jeunes sont livrés à eux mêmes
ils restent à la maison ils sont sur
leur smartphone
on les a perdus des jeunes sédentarisés
qui passent plus de temps devant les
écrans les prises de poids une
augmentation du stress et des angoisses
et les locales redoutent des
conséquences sur le moyen ou long terme
particulièrement dans les quartiers
populaires les sports dans le quartier
est un ciment républicain est déjà en
difficulté hier aujourd'hui avec la
crise sanitaire
ça vient leur donner le coup de massue
parce que le mécénat locale s'est
désengagé cette année et puis surtout
les clubs sportifs ont vécu des noms
réadhésions importante ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui non plus de moyens
aujourd'hui je pose les mots jeudi
qu'une digue républicaine est en train
d'exploser dans nos quartiers populaires
réouvrir les salles les clubs aux
enfants et aux adultes il ya désormais
urgence pour la sénatrice et ancienne du
look à catherine belrhiti un message
qu'elle ne cesse d'affirmer depuis des
mois clamant haut et fort que le sport
c'est le premier geste barrière contre
le coc vide études à l'appui des études
américaines ont montré que les personnes
qui pratiquaient du sport régulièrement
avec deux fois moins de chances de se
retrouver hospitalisés ou même de
contracter une forme grave du co lead
donc pour moi il faut absolument que
l'on travaille au fait de réouvrir ses
salles de repères mais trop aux
personnes de bouger et de refaire du
sport
le monde du sport espère une réouverture
des clubs et des salles dès le mois de
mai alors allons plus loin avec vous il
ya six cocoa ce fils sissoko merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation l'on
sait pas trop par où commencer je le
disais vous avez plein de casquettes
évidemment ancien sportif de haut niveau
mais vous écrivez vous mettez en scène
vous êtes aussi comédienne on va quand
même commencer par le sport dans le
sillage du sujet de marib remo on le
voit bien depuis le coc vide les clubs
enfermé il ya beaucoup d'inquiétude dans
le monde du sport sur ces jeunes qui ne
peuvent plus des pensées qui ne peuvent
plus canalisé est ce que vous partagez
cette inquiétude est bien évident
donc j'ai la partage enfin j'ai pratiqué
le sport pendant vingt ans de ma vie à
ça a été un repère formidable à la fois
humain mais aussi un repère temporel
puisque comme le disait est l'un des
intervenants du reportage le sport
permet de rythmer nos semaines d'avoir
des repères justement dans nos semaines
ça nous permet de nous des pensées ça
nous permet aussi d'être en bonne santé
ça nous permet aussi enfin d'accéder à
un équilibre psychique
ce qui était censé être qui plus est
dans le contexte annie tard qui est le
nôtre et donc oui bien évidemment que je
défends la réouverture des salles de
sport enfin l'arrêt lieu de lien social
aussi de contacts avec un monde qui
n'est peut-être pas celui de la maison
et qui permet de une forme de mixité
sociale
c'est un formidable lieu de
sociabilisation la salle de sport parce
qu on est amené à rencontrer un public
qu'on n'aurait pas rencontré 20 dans un
autre contexte ce soit celui de l'école
ou même celui du milieu social dans
lequel on évolue au quotidien
et donc c'est aussi un lieu qui demande
aussi beaucoup d'attentes d'adaptabilité
c'est à dire dans la pratique mais aussi
aux autres à leur manière de faire de
penser et c'est donc il est
véritablement impératif que les salles
de sport et ouvre le plus rapidement
possible vous avez l'impression qu'en
france on n'a pas bien compris l'intérêt
du sport l'intérêt majeur du sport son
importance en fait c'est vrai que la
manière d'appréhender le sport en france
et très particulière c'est à dire qu'on
a tendance continûment à dissocier le
corps et l'esprit
alors que ce sont enfin deux composantes
d'un complémentaire est essentiel c'est
à dire que je suis l'exemple justement
de d'une personne qui a exercé bain du
sport enfin différents sports pendant
plus de vingt ans de ma vie
et qui est-ce qui a faim et qui est
aussi ben voila a nourri un intellect le
sait quoi justement votre histoire avec
le sport vous parce que en particulier
c'est la boxe je crois vous êtes une
grande championne de boxe championne de
france la championne championne de
france d'europe du monde de boxe
comment vous y est devenu alors par
hasard c'est à dire que on emménage dans
un nouveau lieu
mères qui travaillent de nuit a besoin
de savoir où sont ses enfants quand elle
est absente et donc on va les prendre
ces renseignements près de l'école
du quartier et donc le professeur de
sport lui fait l'article écouter ya du
judo du cir à l'heure du volley ball et
de la boxe
moi du haut de mes sept ans et demi je
veux dire ma mère va dire tout sauf
labeur c'est moi dieu de mes sept ans et
demi je lui dirai si moi je veux la boxe
et elle a essayé effectivement de me
faire changer d'avis mais l'aventuré va
continuer pendant plus de 20 ans et vous
dirais que la boxe vous a sauvé la vie
vous a sauvé quelque chose d'un chagrin
parce que vous avez une histoire
familiale un peu un peu lourde et il a
intégré de dormir comment faire la boxe
a été un véritable exutoire c'est-à-dire
qu'elle m'a permis d'extérioriser
justement tout ce que je peux enfin tout
ce que je ne pouvais pas faire avec les
moore donc voilà par physiquement et
donc la boxe la boxe se soigne
la boxe vous permet de ne pas vous
abîmez vous même en tout cas le ce la
pratique sportive mais c'est vrai que ça
aurait pu être aussi d'autres
disciplines ça aurait pu être l'hôte et
après ça aurait pu être la peinture etc
mais bon il s'est trouvé que moi c'était
la boxe aussi parce que je suis issu
d'un milieu populaire et que je n'avais
pas accès à d'autres à d'autres
activités
mais en tout cas voilà en tout cas
j'encourage enfin enfin tout le monde
que ce soit des filles ou des garçons à
s'adonner à une activité sportive
je parlais d'une histoire familiale
lourdes on y vient parce que vous l'avez
dit vous l'avez écrit et donc ses
publics et je ne dévoile rien je crois
en tout cas d'un team que vous ne
vouliez vous voudriez pas qu'on dise
c'est en 1986 que vous perdez votre père
et votre petite soeur dans un incendie
de votre immeuble un incendie criminel
il faut le préciser voilà c'est ce que
j'allais dire a priori criminel mais
vous le dites vous même il est criminel
l'année d'après vous perdez votre petit
frère d'une méningite non diagnostiquée
cet incendie a été revendiqué par un
groupuscule d'extrême droite
actuellement pour vous c'est un crime
raciste
il n'y a pas de questions il n'y a pas
de doute alors il n'y a pas de là pas de
question à voir c'est à dire que dans le
même temps pendant il ya différents
immeubles qui sont majoritairement
occupés par des familles immigrées
voilà qui sont incendiés
et donc il n'y a pas eu d'appel de
coupable donc pas de condamnation
et donc effectivement où il est
important de dire que cet immeuble n'a
pas pris feu tout seul d'un dea en tout
cas des individus et ont mis le feu donc
voilà on
on disposant des pneus
mettant justement fin des matières
inflammables et en allumant ma
l'allumette ou le briquet je ne sais pas
le racisme c'est quelque chose que vous
avez connu vous très personnellement
dans votre vie tout au long de votre
parcours et peut-être aussi dans le
milieu du sport ou pas alors c'est vrai
que j'ai été confronté au racisme
enfin tout au long de ma vie c'est à
dire que plus jeune j'étais incapable
finalement de l'expliquer de le théorise
et donc il m'a fallu beaucoup de temps
justement de pour comprendre en fait ce
qui nous était arrivé à ma famille à moi
et d'ailleurs c'est ce que je raconte
finalement dans ce texte qui est qui a
été publié dans la croix ou jeudi qu' il
est important finalement en fin de de
dire que les institutions peuvent
produire du racisme parce que suite à
cet incendie
on a demandé justice
et donc on s'est tourné vers elle il
nous a fallu presque dix ans pour
reconnaître que nous étions des victimes
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
très attaché justement au statut du
victimes parce que nous n'avons été donc
je m'en suis bien évidemment détaché
avec le temps mais le disiez ce racisme
vous le vivez tous les jours presque
alors le jour même de manière là de
manière de manière très très insidieuse
c'est assez nette de non racisme n'est
pas n'est pas forcément la personne qui
va vous criez enfin salle noire ou sale
négresse dans la rue dans la rue
mais ça va voilà des petits micros
agression comme on dit alors j'essaie de
vous trouver un exemple très près
rapidement voilà c'est par exemple vous
êtes enceinte vous êtes au labour et
vous attendez des résultats des analyses
vous êtes en train de lire un livre de
stefan zweig est la personne qui est
juste à côté de vous va vous dire mais
vous lisez ça vous voilà donc ce sont
tous temps des petites micro agression
c'est le fait par exemple d'être
enfin championne et que continûment dans
la presse ça va être la championne
d'origine malienne alors donc que ce qui
est sensé sonné justement comme une
addition moi je le fais moi en tout cas
je le ressens comme une soustraction
c'est à dire je ne suis pas tout à fait
français sera pleinement françaises ont
en tout cas française mais est donc la
preuve toute la problématique finalement
réside dans ça et comment vous lutter
contre ce racisme vous aujourd'hui vous
avez choisi quoi l'écriture c'est au
travers de vos choix artistiques comment
comment vous luttez alors mes mails et
fin mai façon de lutter sont
protéiformes donc bien évidemment il à
l'écriture il ya aussi le fait d'être
continuellement sur le terrain d'être en
contact aussi avec celles et ceux bas
qui luttent donc les associations et les
collèges les lycées
enfin les les personnes donc qui sont en
détention
oscillant et aussi pour que aussi pour
que enfin là qu'il n'y ait pas de
rupture justement avec cette réalité
c'est à dire que lorsque l'on lorsque
notre condition sociale évolue en
attendant c'est effectivement un se
déconnecte à la déconnecter justement de
la réalité du terrain et pour moi il est
essentiel justement de rester en contact
avec celles et ceux qui sont les
principaux concernés
la première fois que vous êtes monté sur
scène je crois c'était dans sur la route
une pièce qui s'inspirait d'un fait
violence policière aux états unis en
2015 elle retraçait la dernière journée
de sandra blanc d'une jeune
afro-américaine arrêté lors d'un
contrôle routier retrouvée morte trois
jours plus tard dans sa cellule la
police l'a pas on va parler alors de
suicide alors que sa famille va être
convaincu qu'il s'agissait de violences
policières
l'histoire avait bouleversé l'amérique
d'autant plus que la femme était une
militante du mouvement black la mise
matters est pas anodin de faire ses
débuts sur scène dans une pièce comme
celle là quel était le message
mais le message déjà c'était de dire que
cette femme bun
c'était une femme donc là un être humain
qu'elle avait la vie devant elle et que
l'on peut mourir
justement de l'interaction avec la
police et donc que là on relate un fait
divers qui s'est passé aux états unis
mais cette réalité existe aussi en
france c'est madame il a on va en voir
les potées de la france mais alors
peut-être votre réaction au procès dans
la sphère de georges floyd ou le
policier d'eric chauvine a donc été
condamnés on a vu un immense soulagement
outre atlantique
vous partagez soulagement vous vous
dites que peut-être on est à un tournant
aux états unis dans leur histoire
raciale
alors je ne sais pas c'est un tournant
parce que dans le même temps enfin
quelques heures après et enfin une jeune
fille afro américaine était aussi tué
par la police
mais il était de toute façon il
envisageable que le policier ne soit pas
condamné c'est à dire que le monde
entier a été le témoin de l'agonie de
cet homme
suite à la vidéo qui a été fait par une
jeune femme
il me semble une femme danyellah
fraisiers me semble et donc il ne
pouvait pas en être autrement
on ne pouvait pas effectivement si vous
avez peur que ça change rien finalement
que ce soit bon qu'on est donné ce
verdict un peu aussi pour satisfaire
l'opinion mondiale puisque effectivement
le monde regardait les etats-unis sur ce
verdict mais finalement ça ne change
rien on va dire que voilà sept combats
cette condamnation est symbolique il
fallait de toute façon ça ne pouvait pas
être autrement les images parlent
d'elles mêmes
fin personne de sensé aurait pu enfin
il n'aurait pu enfin n'aurait pas pu
alors d'autres d'autres sanctions que
celle ci il n'empêche que il va falloir
aussi comprendre pourquoi enfin des
jeunes hommes et des jeunes femmes
noires meurt entre les mains de la
police
et donc ça nécessite aussi de comprendre
comment les sociétés occidentales se
structure comment les institutions
policières interagissent avec certains
publics
je vous montrais parce que dans
l'opinion on peut lire le criminologue
américain philip stinson ne croit pas
lui que la sphère floyd débouche sur un
changement systémique des forces de
l'ordre aux états unis et il dit il y a
dans la culture profonde des officiers
de police américains une peur des noirs
voilà ce qu'il écrit est ce que vous
feriez un parallèle avec la france vous
iriez jusque là pour qualifier peut-être
l'état d'esprit de la police française
en tout cas je suis je peux enfin je
peux affirmer parce que j'ai grandi dans
un quartier populaire et que
effectivement enfin les liens police et
jeunes et particulièrement jeunes
racisés est très très compliqué je dis
juste effectivement que il ya un
véritable racisme structurel en france
vous aller jusque là moi je feins je
vous dit pas il y à des policiers
racisme dans un racisme les préjugés moi
je dis qu'il ya un racisme structurel et
qu'il ya donc des discrimination
systémique et que des jeunes hommes non
blancs meurt entre les mains de la
police et qu'il faut comprendre
effectivement comment cela enfin
commencer enfin structurelles qu'est ce
qui vous fait aller jusqu'à dire que
c'est structurel
quels sont les éléments dont vous
disposez pour le dire tout simplement
c'est que
il feint il ya une histoire justement
fin de l'esclavagé de la colonisation il
y à il ya une histoire justement de la
gestion des corps non blancs aussi aussi
en france bien évidemment donc il est
donc tout ça effectivement enfin c'est
une explosion à 7,8
on a été conditionné c'est à dire qu'on
est pétri finalement deux
représentations et des préjugés et donc
qu'ils agissent sans même que l'on s'en
rende compte
et donc ces corps sont perçus comme
étant dangereux et donc en tout cas pour
les dépositaires enfin
enfin pour les défunts pour les forces
de la donc un traitement différencié
donc par rapport à d'autres populations
donc vous soutenez des associations
comme le comité à damas ah ça traoré qui
est devenu une grande figure de l'anti
racisme et de la lutte contre les
violences policières contre les
personnes noah vous vous êtes de salon -
effectivement j'avoue que je suis je
suis de très près fait quand il va faire
à la main et d'ailleurs je me dis que
moins d'un an après il ya une décision
de justice qui a été rendue dans la
sphère du rove floyd là ça va faire
bientôt cinq ans que la famille que les
amis que le site tient enfin réclame
vérité justice et qu on en est quasiment
au point mort et donc qu'est ce qui
justifie effectivement que ça prenne
autant de temps
moi c'est justement c'est ce que je me
voilà le mot l'interrogation est là qu
est ce qui justifie effectivement que
tient enfin voilà que la tenue d'un
procès prenne autant de temps
on a aujourd'hui un président et un
gouvernement qui essaie de travailler
sur les questions de diversité notamment
la demande d'emmanuelle macron la
ministre déléguée chargée de la ville
nadia a lancé portrait de france qui
regroupe 318 personnalités issues de la
diversité qui ont marqué l'histoire et
qui pourraient devenir des noms de rues
et des noms de bâtiments officiels
est-ce que c'est typiquement le genre de
démarches que vous soutenez que vous
saluer de soissons bien évidemment que
je soutiens tous démarche qui va dans le
sens de la reconnaissance finalement
enfin voilà d'individus d'hommes et de
femmes qui ont fait la france et qui
jusque fin que jusqu'à là qui était
totalement un visibiliser
par contre moi j'aimerais qu'on aille
encore plus loin
c'est à dire que ces histoires soient
prises aussi dans les livres d'histoire
on sait pertinemment que quand on passe
dans une rue on voit là on ne prend pas
forcément le temps de lire le nom qui
est inscrit sur la plaque
d'autant plus que voilà on a une date
une date une date de naissance et une
date fin de deux morts éventuellement
enfin voilà une la fonction qui a été
écrite en dessous mais on ne sait pas
qui sont ces gens là
alors que dans les livres d'histoire
justement inclure toutes les personnes
qui ont été jusqu'ici un visibiliser
d'assurer pour moi un symbole fort
un symbole fort c'est à dire que tous
les enfants se sentir et finalement
appartenir à cette histoire de france
parce qu'ils sont l'histoire de france
c'est à dire que mon destin français
n'est pas le fruit du hasard
j'appartiens à l'histoire de france
parce qu'il fait quand mes parents
décident de venir s'installer en france
ils ne le font pas par hasard
c'est à dire que le mali est une
ancienne colonie française
au milieu des années 60 la france a
besoin de bras pour construire ces
routes pour voilà pour commander un de
bras pour remplir ses usines et donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle il vient
de temps en france et donc voilà c'est
important juste pour vous mettre ces
personnes dans les livres d'histoire
serait une des clés de l'intégration de
gênes qui peut-être ne se sentent pas
complètement intégrée à la france est en
se disant là à l'école j'apprends ça
alors dont je fais partie du peuple
français je trouve que c'est essentiel
c'est à dire je suis français prend ou
française à part entière
voilà mes aïeux en partie si tôt c'est
la libération de la france qui a été
aussi le cas de mon grand père c'est à
dire que mon grand père paternel fait la
seconde guerre mondiale et participe
justement à libération la france et là
aussi on ne parle pas du principe de
blanchiment d'image c'est à dire que les
premiers soldats à être entrés dans
paris étaient issus des colonies
françaises ce ne sont pas les soldats
blancs qu'on a l'habitude de nous
montrer à l'image et rouge et
aujourd'hui cette visibilité doit aller
plus loin que l'histoire vous pensé à
d'autres je sais pas aux médias par
exemple ça doit aller plus loin
mais bien évidemment parce que cette
visibilité ce serait c'est l'image d'un
de ski ce qui est dans la rue c'est à
dire la réalité finalement dû du dehors
et donc voilà il faut que tous ces
talents toutes ces compétences
finalement soit
désolé pour les quotas alors vous auriez
par exemple pour moi j'aurais posé
décodage je voulais je voulais
sincèrement effectivement je suis pour
les quotas c'est à dire qu'on a vu aussi
d'un pour les pour les femmes en
politique qu'il a fallu instaurer des
quotas pour qu'elle puisse exister au
sein enfin voilà au sein des partis au
sein de l'hémicycle et c est donc je ne
vois pas pourquoi on ne pourrait pas
d'eux mêmes
en tout cas ne serait-ce temporairement
pour van justement si ça marche ou pas
ben dans tout ce qui est dans tout ce
qui appartient aux sphères médiatiques
et autres parmi vos engagements il ya
celui pour l'afrique aussi le continent
donc de naissance de vos parents vous
l'avez dit qu'ils viennent du mali vous
raconter cette histoire familiale dans
un livre co écrit avec marie desplechin
d'un bed and b oui dame bédanne mais qui
a russe signifie pardon d'imiter dignité
et qui a reçu en 2009 le grand prix de
l'héroïne madame figaro
et puis plus récemment vous avez
participé à l' ouvrage image in africa
2060 qui se projette sur l'avenir du
continent africain comment vous le voyez
l'avenir du continent africain bah
écoutez je pense que de toute façon
l'avenir sont justement dans dans ces
espaces que l'on dit émergents parce que
c'est aussi là que se trouve la jeunesse
une jeunesse qui
à qui de plus en plus créatrices voilà
qu'il ya de plus en plus envie d'exister
et donc voilà qui inventent de nouvelles
formes d'interaction de nouvelles formes
de création etc et donc
oui je pense d'abord les qu'on parle de
façon positive du continent africain
parce que effectivement dans les médias
français quand on parle de l'afrique on
parle malheureusement de misère de
guerre aujourd'hui de terrorisme et
c'est en ça et c'est la raison pour
laquelle justement que je spécifie dans
mes écrits que déjà au xiiie siècle à
soundiata keita avait instauré certains
droits humains que l'on retrouve dans la
déclaration des droits de l'homme
mais ça personne n'en parle et c'est
essentiel justement de le dire justement
pour que les enfants issue justement de
ces espaces puisse avoir des éléments de
narcissique pour se construire
positivement il ne suscite aucune
inquiétude quand même pour vous le
continent africain et je pense
particulièrement au mali qui est
malheureusement le théâtre de deux
combats entre groupes jihadistes dans
laquelle d'ailleurs la france est très
impliqué vous avez une inquiétude quand
même au fond de vous notamment pour le
mali 1 je pense aux fins de ta sont
enfin là où là où se trouvent des fins
je suis inquiète bien évidemment en tant
qu'être humain c'est à dire que voilà
j'ai une empathie pour celles et ceux
qui subissent qui subissent la guerre
donc oui si pour le mali bien évidemment
mais ils ont vu un changement ou pas
vous avez vu quelque chose qui se passe
et on m'a dit qu'ils étaient alors par
contre ce qui est formidable aussi c'est
que moi je ne suis jamais enfin j'y suis
allé au mali une seule fois et j'avais 3
ans donc c'est à dire que certains une
connaissance beaucoup plus pointue du
manic ans que moi mais il n'empêche
effectivement que je regarde
effectivement du coin de l'oeil ce qui
s'y passe parce que j'ai encore de la
famille qui vit et que je m'inquiète
effectivement pour leur quotidien pour
leur vie mais mais voilà le problème du
mali est très très complexe et le lien
qu à la france avec le continent
africain et avec plusieurs pays
africains en particulier je pense
notamment emmanuel macron qui s'est ému
de la mort du président tchadien idriss
déby d'ailleurs il va aux obsèques
demain je pense à cette implication de
la france au sahel
ce lien
la france avec le continent africain
vous diriez qu'il a évolué dans le bon
sens qu'on est sortis du lien
françafrique du lien cole ont colonisé
ou pas je pense que on n'y est pas
encore mais c'est ce sont des sujets qui
sont très très complexes que je ne
maîtrise pas d'enjeu d'éviter finalement
de m'étendre dessus mais il ya encore
beaucoup à faire je veux dire qu'il ya
encore très peu de temps un président
enfin disait que l'afrique n'est pas
encore entré dans l'histoire donc voilà
c'est que il ya encore justement enfin
voilà un rapport enfin très con c'est
donc très condescendant justement de
l'occident envers l'afrique
mais c'est un sujet que je ne maîtrise
pas donc je les mêmes avocats il
souhaite quand même que l'occident en
voix par exemple il l'a fait savoir fin
février 13 millions de doses de vaccin
en afrique
ça c'est pour vous quelque chose de
positif venant du gouvernement français
de l'exécutif français
écoutez c'est beau c'est véritablement
un sujet que je ne maîtrise absolument
pas et donc jamais vous pourriez vous
dire effectivement effectivement
sélectivement c'est formidable mais je
ne sais pas effectivement enfin où on
est la crise sanitaire enfin quelle est
l'ampleur de la crise sanitaire au mali
voilà je n'ai absolument aucune de ces
données donc voilà ce qu'il est
véritablement utile d'envoyer 13
millions de doses au mali je ne sais pas
donc c'est la raison pour la corne
d'afrique 1 voilà on africa ou alors en
plus en afrique donc voilà donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle effectivement je ne
vais pas m'étendre sur le sujet et on
s'arrêtera là merci infiniment il ya
sissoko d'avoir été le train derrière le
soir